congratulations I've just made you
brighter
I'm sixty one point two meters
underground with twenty million tons of
rock above my head and I'm under the
town of Bendigo in Australia not far
from Melbourne as part of my lecture
tour and I'm in a gold mine never been
in a gold mine before and Tropius the
main guide has been taking us around if
you don't see it it can't be gold
telling us about how gold is mined I
never knew at the mechanics and he's
even given me a piece of gold to hold
not to cave know not to keep that's the
size of the pieces of gold that are
found in the mine they don't find huge
nuggets unfortunately what I want to
tell you about is another recent paper
in a journal this time in the journal
Nature and there is a paper which tries
to explain why it is that you find gold
in some places like here in Bendigo and
not all over the surface of the earth
it's really good and never seen go
before in its natural state it's really
quite exciting
you see geologists and space scientists
have always wondered because the earth
began as a really molten ball of iron
and minerals why the heavy elements
didn't all sink to the center of the
earth I've got a small object here just
to help you see this this is a scarf and
you can see if you look at this scarf
that you have the light elements at the
top and all the heavy ones have sent
down to the bottom so as you imagine the
heavy elements would go to the center of
the earth which you'd have to dig down
thousands of miles to get to the gold
because gold is a really heavy element
one of the very
missed elements there is and even though
we're sixty 1.2 meters down we're still
near the Earth's surface because as you
know the earth is eight thousand miles
in diameter so this is just a tiny bit
down so why is there gold so near the
surface and the theory is and what this
paper has been believes they have proved
is that early in the Earth's history but
once it was already solid large objects
asteroids and so on slammed into the
Earth's surface when it was already
solid and spread these elements near the
surface and because they did went in
particular places not all over the
Earth's surface then you get some places
where they're gold and other elements
the paper itself was about tungsten but
you don't get it uniformly all over the
surface so if you're lucky low enough to
live in a place like here Bendigo you
dig thousands of mines in the hope of
getting lots of gold but if you dug the
same number of holes in Nottingham where
I live all you get is coal not a trace
of gold i le scientists seriously
suggesting that the salt for example the
site here where Bendigo is had chunks of
gold landing from outer space
no they're suggesting that you have an
asteroid or something which contains
heavy metals which slammed into an area
probably much bigger than this and in
the melting and whatever caused by the
collision that deposits of the heavier
metals were formed around this area I
think that sounds pretty good to me was
that used to you oh well I like the idea
of an asteroid impact caused either
certainly it's more fun but definitely
it explains why so much gold we found in
Bendigo but almost not another
to the world there's loud then there's
this because what you've experienced
minor competitor well
so here is the paper and because of the
way they do the measurements which is
using isotopes they've actually analyzed
tungsten in the rocks rather than gold
but they have then generalized from
tungsten to all the noble metals so the
heavy metals like gold platinum iridium
and so on so and because it's an
exciting result they have published a
simpler explanation for those who are
not specialists here talking about the
Earth's patchy veneer in the diagram
here they first of all show how
everything concentrates in the Earth's
core and then here you can see things
slamming into the Earth's surface
bringing in later on if you like in the
Earth's history these heavy metals I
think it's important to say that if you
went into outer space now and found an
asteroid or something like that it
wouldn't contain large lumps of gold but
it would have the gold aspra distributed
around it much the same way as in the
area around here so there's no point
going by rocket hoping that you get rich
quick because you won't so a lot of
restaurants had to here for this to
happen well they're not clear whether
it's a lot of small ones or some rather
larger ones but it's the principle
that's being discussed here